Everyone's favorite frightening doll is back,
and we're not talking about Chucky.
We're talking about Annabelle, the messed-up
face of the Conjuring universe.
According to critics, this creepy toy's third
spinoff movie, Annabelle Comes Home, looks
like another big winner for the horror franchise.
Congratulations, Annabelle!
While there was a moratorium on full reviews
being published in the lead-up to the movie's
release, Annabelle Comes Home was screened
in advance for a few select critics, and their
early reactions on Twitter were pretty positive.
The general consensus?
Series writer Gary Dauberman, making his directorial
debut with this threequel, has delivered an
atmospheric, creepy thrill ride that easily
bests the previous Annabelle flicks in terms
of flat-out fun.
Rather than focusing on the doll's origins
in decades past like the previous two films,
Annabelle Comes Home brings things, well,
home, tying itself in with the original Conjuring
series much more closely than the spinoff
series has before.
The movie prominently features the demonologists
Lorraine and Ed Warren, the main characters
in The Conjuring and its sequel.
Annabelle Comes Home chronicles the terrifying
events that unfold when the Warrens sequester
the doll inside their Artifacts Room for safekeeping...only
to find out that her presence has some unexpected
and rather unfortunate consequences.
"The doll, it's a beacon for other spirits."
In this movie, Annabelle and these other spirits
all pose a grave threat to the Warrens' young
daughter, Judy, as well as a pair of particularly
unlucky babysitters who've been tasked with
watching over her.
Attempting to describe the film, Conjuring
universe mastermind James Wan said:
"[It's] basically A Night at the Museum, with
Annabelle."
The critics who caught preview screenings
of Annabelle Comes Home generally agree that
the film is just as fun and over-the-top as
Wan's description suggests.
CinemaBlend's Eric Eisenberg claims that the
Annabelle series just keeps getting better
and better.
The critic wrote,
"Excited I can now say Annabelle Comes Home
is excellent, solidifying the trilogy as a
rare one that improves with each sequel.
The cast is fantastic, the monster mayhem
is surprisingly clever, and the whole experience
is just super fun.
It's a big win for The Conjuring Universe."
Silas Lesnick of MovieBill was pleased to
report that the new crop of spirits didn't
feel forced, thanks to some smart narrative
choices.
"I'm thrilled to report that [Annabelle Comes
Home] is great!
It has a smart script, fantastic performances
and it expands the Conjuring universe in some
really clever ways.
Mostly, though, it's just a ton of fun!"
Eric Francisco of Inverse was similarly impressed
with the film's array of supernatural threats,
calling the movie
"An atmospheric thrill that cements The Conjuring
franchise as THE horror movie universe to
reckon with.
There's plenty more than just parlor tricks
in the Warrens' forbidden room than you might
expect."
While Wan's Night at the Museum comparison
makes for an enticing blender pitch, Fandango's
Erik Davis compared the horror film to another
quirky comedy, one which might make you even
more excited to see what the movie has in
store.
He wrote,
"[Annabelle Comes Home] is like Adventures
in Babysitting as a horror movie, and it's
a damn good time.
The scares are never repetitive, the humor
is on point & there are plenty of creepy entities
to freak you out.
Plus, I love movies where it's up to the babysitter
to save the day."
Finally, Dread Central's Jonathan Barkan weighed
in on the film, and, while he was careful
to avoid spoilers, he offered up a few general
thoughts on Twitter, saying:
"Seriously, I loved this movie.
Had a genuine blast with it and I can't recommend
it enough!"
Of course, he might only be saying that because
of the special guest he says he saw the screening
with.
While the consensus may change as more reviews
come in, the early buzz is unanimous: Annabelle
Comes Home is a bona fide success, and potentially
a high point for the whole Conjuring franchise.
Take a bow, Annabelle!
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
horror films are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.